[Music]
Angelina Jolie walked the red carpet at
the Dumbo premiere on Monday night but
it was her kids that stole the show the
director and four of her six kiddos made
an appearance at the star-studded event
at the El Capitan Theatre in LA that's
Zahara Shiloh and the twins Vivian and
Knox you can do it Dumbo
sure
[Music]
while the 43 year old actress doesn't
have a role in the live-action remake
she will be returning to the big screen
for a different Disney film Maleficent
mistress of evil oh it was originally
set for a 2020 release date but the
studio's surprised fans announcing the
movie will be coming to theaters on
October 18th 2019 cheering this pic to
Twitter in may twenty eighteen Disney
shared this pic from set that same day
they posted these shots writing here's
your first look at Angelina Jolie and Al
Fanning as Maleficent and Aurora I know
that your kids actually helped you out
with the voice of Maleficent did they
actually help you out with that evil
laugh that you have in the movie as well
with everything they basically picked
everything they're here tonight they're
there inside waiting that was Angie in
2014 at the premiere of Maleficent where
she dished on her daughter Vivian's
small role in the film she actually seen
herself in the movie yet she saw a rough
cut but she hasn't seen like when the
tree picks her up and stuff like that
she's probably be very confused you know
wait I didn't do that at verse says that
yeah what did you think about being does
she get the fact that she's in a big
movie she just likes dressed up and
hanging out with mommy you know like any
other kids so I think she'll fight her
brothers and sisters are probably find
it more fun I see it if they all say not
be to be in a dress and out and you know
she wants to know what kind of candy we
have at the theater you know she's she's
she's thinking all the right things